Recording
gone like no.
Oh,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click
on the link for the fleshlight,
enter in the code name,
Rogan,
you get 15% off the
number one male sex toy.
Oh righty.
Buck a lot.
Bitches.
Here we go out and girls in the house,
the Joe Rogan experience,
black gay man.
What the fuck?
[inaudible]
she's still not safe.
Black guy on me,
man.
That's not cool.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
the Godfather of the podcast is here.
The man has started at all the man who
without him I probably might not have
done this fucking thing.
I might not have been,
uh,
so enthusiastic about doing it,
but doing his was so much
fun and he was so smart to,
to jump right into that right
after his radio station.
Adam Carolla ways and Joe,
great to be here.
Great to have you buddy.
It's real man.
If it wasn't for you and you know,
and doing your podcast and
realizing how like you had it.
So,
I mean,
now you've got it really professional.
Like the last time I was there I was like,
Holy Shit.
He's like stacks of
compressors and all this,
you know,
and monitors and people hidden
video switches and everything.
I mean,
you've got it like a,
it's a goddamn studio.
You,
you know,
uh,
everyone is at that studio is still
making fun of me because Joe did that
podcast couple of weeks ago and uh,
Joe took a tour around the back part of
the warehouse and we're up at the front
part where the studio is.
And then Joe came back and he said to me,
man,
you got all these compressors.
And I said,
really?
You haven't seen shit yet buddy?
And I said,
follow me.
And we walked to a closet and I opened
it up and I turned that turn the light on
and there was a 40 gallon
air compressor there.
And I said,
that's the granddaddy of them all.
And he went,
no,
I didn't mean air compressors.
And I was like,
what other kind of compressor
would you be talking about?
And then my,
my buddy started laughing at me.
And now,
uh,
I'm ridiculed soundly.
I stand by my compressor
means a compressor.
Well,
Jimmy,
you were correct and that is
the original use of compressor.
Yeah.
Especially considering that
you have an auto garage.
That's a rare situation.
Where was a good looking compressor?
I showed you can be sure.
Right?
Well listen,
I'm,
I'm as a into gadgets as
the next fella and I'm,
I'm very impressed by
that large compressor.
I mean,
that was something you expect
to see at a gas station.
Thank you.
Very nice.
Even though now they charge
you a fucking quarter,
75 cents up to street or whatever.
I mean,
just the whole idea.
I would love to,
you know,
they do that stuff where they go,
if our founding fathers could
see this fuck founding fathers,
let me get a couple of
guys from the fifties yeah.
And just drag them in and go,
they make you pay for air.
I should black in their eye.
You know what I mean?
I mean like a guy of the
bow tie and it's like,
oh,
you know,
just just take a guy from
the 50s and show him a gas,
serve yourself,
uh,
you clean your own windshield,
you need to pay in advance.
That'd be another thing.
Like they don't trust you,
uh,
air they'll charge for,
for the option to pump my own gas.
It's one thing that creeps me out about,
about like,
um,
I think Oregon has and I know New
Jersey has it or they don't let you,
they don't vet you pumped your gas.
Yeah.
For Real.
They don't allow you to,
that is a weird one,
isn't it?
Very strange.
I have,
uh,
I've,
I've done some,
some,
uh,
I don't know if we were
talking about this before,
but I,
I was thinking about
this sort of gas station.
Like I tell people,
you know,
you can decide where to live.
A lot of people base that on like,
well,
how are the school systems or how well,
you know,
what's going on with the economy
or the roads or something.
But I would say you can base
your neighborhood on the
gas station cause there's
sort of three levels.
There are the ones like the ones in my
neighborhood where you swipe your credit
card and then you have to punch in your
zip code because of credit card fraud.
Then there's the slightly
nicer neighborhood where
you just swipe your credit
card but you don't have to punch in your
zip code and then there's the greatest
neighborhoods of all where you just pump
your gas and when you're done you pay
somebody but you don't.
They don't need cash up front.
I mean that's when you travel and you
get outside of La and you realize,
oh there's just some guy's going to let
you pump your gas and then you can pay
him like not everyone's
fucking Bonnie and Clyde.
I was like,
all of us are going to jump off spray
sliding across our hoods laughing and
peeling out that is,
that means you're in a good God damn
neighborhood and they trust you.
That's absolutely true.
You know I got credit card fraud
fraud to do get to the other day.
Just a couple.
Just a week or so ago.
I'm super paranoid now.
I'm always at the gas station,
like trying to pull off the
standard and make sure it's real.
Know how they do it.
Those scanners,
when you scan your card
at the gas station,
they put a scanner over that.
So as you're scanning it's getting there,
getting your numbers as well.
And they also have a little
camera that looks like like a,
a an advertisement for a credit card.
Uh,
the facade,
the application has a little camera
in here that reads you typing in your
number.
So as you type in your area
code or your Zip Code Zip code,
right.
You got to do that weird back hunch thing.
Yeah.
You gotta put your hand like
this street and food in prison.
I wonder if there's going to
be some sort of syndrome that,
um,
that doctors are going to run into and
chiropractors are going to run into
called block ATM back where
like in the next hundred years,
our kids are going to have weird
Scully and spines from doing that weird
shoulder hunch.
Talk,
punching it.
It's really,
you get it from,
it's,
it's sorta what carpal tunnel tunnel list.
The guys who were keyboard jobs all day.
This is a weird back hunch to all the
people that go to the ATM three times a
week and dial in their zip code
when they're at the gas station.
Do the cell phone thing where they're
like texting is going to be a weird cause
it is this weird,
oh this is heavy.
This may be the weed talking but
we may be dig this,
just dig this.
We may be getting taller as a species
but we're evening it out by hunching over
all the time and rolling our shoulders
and protecting whatever cereal called
codes
punch in.
Yes.
It's weird to me that we still sign
things that freaks me out when I scribble
something on a piece of
paper and it makes it valid.
Right.
The really that real dumbest thing.
We've talked about the how like I just
type in Brad Pitt or Tom Selleck cause
that doesn't write it cause I used to be
kind of meticulous about my autograph,
you know and restart right.
My name out.
I should say my signature.
Right.
If I autograph something,
I'm much more in particular.
Then if I signed
something I signs on that.
I'm just writing some fucking motion.
You can't tell me that's not right.
I'm changing it.
Mark and a,
you know,
you,
you do shows,
you stay afterward,
you sign a bunch of Shit,
right?
I'm sure.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I do the same thing and it's just,
it becomes your mark and I
realized it doesn't have to read.
I always tell people this,
like if people aren't,
if you are going to go out
and get a fake autograph,
it would be Brad Pitt's
Mata graft wouldn't be made.
But it,
so,
I mean,
who's going to question it?
Well,
I've seen fake ones of mine sold online.
We have,
yeah,
a bunch of them from newsradio
member autographed memorabilia.
There's a fake,
everyone,
everyone's name was fake.
I like those guys who once in
a while when you fly into JFK,
there'll be some fat guy in cargo
shorts who sweating profusely.
He's waiting for you.
And he's like big fan,
big fan.
Big Fan.
As you saying,
big fan.
He's just keep swiping just 119
pictures of me as death on the fan.
Like I said,
big fan,
big fan.
Really.
I mean,
it's a big part.
We definitely the 322 pounds.
Do you sign all those though?
I usually,
I'll tell you what happened.
I ran into the same dude on the
way out as I did on the way in,
and I signed about 20
of them on the way out.
And then when I was coming in at like
6:00 AM he was waiting for me again and I
was like,
all right,
I'll give you a 10 this time.
That's nice you,
I,
you know my fee.
I don't,
I don't know why,
but I'm a,
I feel sorry for these guys.
Right?
I mean,
come on.
Yeah.
When's the last time
they got a good blow job,
number one.
Number two.
All right.
So that's their job.
Like they get up at five,
they drive down to JFK,
they pay 20 bucks for parking,
and they wait for Adam Carolla
to come walking up terminal.
Whatever I look at it is,
fuck it.
It's their job.
Right.
I don't really,
I don't give a shit.
How much money can you make off of
you make some pretty decent money.
I it definitely depends.
But like I think I saw your
ship going for like $25.
I know it was just some 25 bucks,
something like that.
I always suspect that just hope on the
off chance the plane will crash then
they'll have a stack of the
last shit you ever sign.
I don't,
I couldn't see him make it much,
much after that.
Yeah.
That could work.
Very Glover.
Yeah.
I used to actually do that.
Um,
like when
I was a kid I would like I,
it was a huge Steve Martin Fan,
so I actually wanted his autograph.
So I would like always go to those uh,
movie shops where they have like the
signed autographs and like the minimum
memorabilia and stuff like
that and always looking for a,
Steve Martin never got one.
And then I found out that
he doesn't give autographs.
He gives out a little business
card and it just says,
this is business card says that you have
met Steve Martin or something like that
and just carries a pocket,
a pocket of them.
I like it when guys are clever but not
that clever that's bordering on cue.
I,
one of the most uncomfortable moments
in my life was me sitting next to Kareem
Abdul Jabbar.
Actually,
I had to wildly uncomfortable moments
that involved Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
One is,
he just sat down on my
radio show and I was like,
you know,
you never see any,
any guys in their seventies that are,
you know,
over six,
seven or six,
eight.
And I,
I mean I,
you know,
I,
I'm not trying to bring you down,
you literally,
but is there some syndrome or have you
talked to somebody or how does it work?
Cause you just don't see seven
footers that are 80 years old,
but yet you seem like you're in perfect
health and I don't know how it works and
if there's something
that I'm not aware of it.
And he's like,
what are you talking about?
And I was like,
you know how you don't see a lot
of old guys who like over six,
five,
they seem to go a little earlier in life.
So my fact,
the little short Jewish guys,
the ones that go on forever,
is there some connection
correlation between the height
and the short longevity.
And he was like,
I never thought about it.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
Really?
And was like,
yeah,
now I am this kind of uncomfortable.
Like I was like,
but no,
but how do you bring this up?
So he,
uh,
he did that to me and then we're this
like dodger all star game or something,
celebrity game and we're sitting next to
each other waiting for the real dodger
game to end in like the,
you know,
the timing of the Sorta,
dug out eating hot wings or something
like this up on the Lowe's level.
And some kid came by and said,
could you sign my baseball?
And I signed this baseball.
And then he handed it to Kareem
Abdul Jabbar and he said,
could you sign my baseball?
And he's like,
uh,
no.
And,
and the kid was like,
really?
Cause it just take a second.
And he's like,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not doing that right now.
And I'm seeing like right next to him
and the kid comes back for a third like
round.
He's like,
you know,
just real quick.
And he was like,
no,
I'm sorry.
Wow.
And I'm like,
just fucking sign it.
Just sign it.
And then he walks away and then his mom
shows up like 10 minutes later and she
was like,
I'm so sorry to disturb you,
Mr Abdul Jabbar.
But um,
the ball for my son,
he's such a huge fan.
Do you think you could just take a moment?
It's like,
sorry.
No,
and she's like,
just,
just a moment and,
and she's like,
no,
thank you.
And I'm just like,
I'm sitting next to him wanting to crawl
out of my urethra and just go under the
carpet.
You know that thing,
having to pretend like,
you know,
that body language that
says I'm not listening.
Like we can all know
the fake body language.
I am listening,
but I'm trying to discover the,
I'm not really listening.
You start leaning a little in God and she
really asked like three or four times.
He's like,
sorry.
No.
And she's like,
I'm really,
because we could have
signed it in this time.
It took,
no,
I'm sorry.
No,
she's like,
Holly,
I would've got all fucking sign it.
I'll eat your pussy.
Whatever.
Please go lay with tape.
Thank your son somewhere
and then it's fucked up.
Yeah,
I guess.
I mean,
no,
he's around.
No,
the point is the midpoint.
We'll Chamberlain's done.
Yeah,
we'll instead.
The point,
the point is,
um,
he,
I realized the guy seven four,
there's not a place.
It's,
it's about height.
I mean,
your spotted your stop.
He gets stopped everywhere.
He goes.
I'm not defending the guy,
but that guy has probably
been bugged for autographs.
None stop for 50 years.
And I bet he's just fucking
head unimpacted asphalt of it.
Betty has.
But he should reconsider
the way that in that case,
especially little kids,
some kid,
and you can make their day,
it's so easy to make their day.
You're going to have to communicate with
them and he's right there and you're
sure it,
I'm listening to the choir talking to you.
You sure it was him,
right?
It wasn't a guy who just looked like yes.
A six [inaudible] four black guy changed
his name from Lew Alcindor Doula.
Who was Lew Alcindor.
Yeah,
I was thinking like I was,
I was joking about this
once where I was saying,
you know,
Cat Stevens,
uh,
Cassius clay,
Lew Alcindor all really bitch and names
like no reason to take the muzzle.
It's true.
Trickle should take the Muslim name
but not maybe even Dick Butkus but not
Cassius clay.
Like cat Steve's like
you guys already are.
We're blessed with some of the
coolest names on the planet.
You know,
much less pussy.
You're going to get cat.
Steven's going to ease left
Muslim or whatever the fuck it is.
I mean that you're going to cut
the putsy spicket off imagining.
Imagine his agent.
How does that,
oh,
how'd the phone call go with his agent?
Hey Marty.
Yeah,
no,
I'm not going by cat anymore.
That's uh,
that's my slave name now.
Non Cat Stevens now I'm going to,
now I'm going to be shelling my next
album is going to be the best of Yousef
Islam.
Cause agent must have just been like,
oh you fucking kidding me.
I was fascinated by his whole situation
is transformation up until I read the
fact that he actually supported the
flat trois as it were or whatever.
Against the guy who rode 'em.
What the fuck is his name?
The Guy who wrote the book,
the one they went after him.
The first guy.
The Muslim guy.
Yeah.
Satanic Verses.
And uh,
that guy was named Gary Keller.
Well you should have gotten me,
I'll spit it out in a second.
Hold on.
So tannic versus just comes
out with Duncan Trussell.
It's so beautiful how you can do that.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well that's a problem and
rushed Salman Rushdie.
These guys are like all these guys there.
There's,
yeah,
there's the Cat Stevens version and then
there's the tea bag or version and it's
always like they,
they,
they explain,
they're like general look,
it's about peace.
It's about a pilgrimage of
spirituality or whatever.
And you go like,
okay,
I'm down,
I'm down.
And then then they,
then they always do something and you go,
all right,
now I get it.
You're an asshole.
He's fucking crazy.
I mean,
look,
Islam is a strange one to convert to.
It's like when Glenn Beck became a Mormon.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You're,
you're like a fucking grown man.
You're a grown man.
He become a Mormon.
It's one thing if you're
like born a Mormon,
raised a Mormon.
I had a joke that I was doing in my act
where the reason why Mormons are so anti
gay marriage is because
they're afraid of gay people.
Rightly so.
Because if someone could
talk into being a Mormon,
they can probably talk
in a sock in her to,
as a matter of how much alone
time they spend with you.
What,
what?
Why don't you believe you pluck?
It is weird.
When people discover stuff at
age 37 I feel like my brain,
like the cement in the sidewalk and my
brain was dry to almost any other ideas
at that point.
We could break that cement
open with some mushrooms.
Oh my God.
Oh,
I have,
I'm sure you have.
Oh,
I had this idea to though,
speaking of the gays,
you'll big this idea again.
This is more just stone talk,
but there's this race that's really fun.
It's called the 24 hours of Lemons
and it's not 24 hours of Le Mall.
It's lemons.
You take a piece of shit car and you're
up against a bunch of other $500 cars
and it's a 24 hour race of piece of shit.
It sounds fun.
So someone says,
well,
how do you know that some guys not going
to spend 10 grand on a car putting like
a souped up engine in it and all that?
How,
how,
how can you confirm that everyone here
hasn't spent more than $500 on their
entry?
It's tough.
And the guy said,
here's how we do it.
We have a giant,
uh,
like bulldozer,
just like a rock crusher,
just like a backhoe things.
She's a cruncher.
And we will go up and down the line
to everyone who enters the race,
every race.
And we'll pick one car and we'll put it
in the crunch here and that sends the
message.
Don't get slick because you look
too slick or we think you're,
you don't want to be the
nicest car at that thing.
You don't want to spend 10 grand
because they'll crunch you.
And then I thought this is how
they should do the gay games,
because I thought,
how do you know everyone
in this game is gay?
Maybe there's some straight guy
who wants to just gave ash legal,
so,
so how do they know?
Like Brock Lesnar when
enter boxing competition
go,
yeah,
Chicago bears beat the shit
out of a bunch of gay guys,
so be the greatest.
I said they should do it the same
way they do the 24 hours and lemons.
It's just they line up all the guys for
the gay games and one guy just walks in
front of them.
It stops in front of one
dune goes suck my cock.
That would keep this
one straight dude away.
Just the 1% chance.
Maybe there'd be a few dudes at risk.
It
just fucking sweat out shows,
right?
Lottery goes right?
They've got an emergency
ecstasy in your pocket.
No,
no.
When the guy,
yeah,
he probably would do it too.
No,
because then you'd read about cognitive.
You realize people are going,
see this,
this is going to make it on youtube.
Yeah.
1980.
You could pull that off.
What was your first car?
I thought you were gonna say cock,
but it was your first car.
My first car was a Mazda pickup truck.
Got 79 Mazda long bed with a,
it didn't have,
you used to have a bench seat in it,
but someone took out the bench
seat and put dinette seats in it.
So it was like theoretically bucket seats,
but they came from someone's living room.
So it wasn't,
it wasn't awesome.
How'd you get,
I like wrapped up in loving cars.
Did you,
uh,
hanging out with Jay Leno too much or,
I was deprived,
uh,
early on of all things mechanical
and I had a ranching gene.
So,
uh,
the wrenching gene,
the wrench or gene,
that mechanical gene,
it's no different than the musical one.
You know,
you always,
whenever they say they
talk about a drummer,
look,
oh,
Tommy Lee was banging on pots and pans
and the in the kitchen when he was three.
So he eventually broke down and got him
a drum kit and he's never left it since,
you know,
so whatever he had that gene,
and some people haven't musical gene and
some people have it for math and some
people have it for conversation or
socializing or whatever science,
whatever.
There is a mechanical gene.
And if you have it and let somebody
gets you that equivalent of a drum kit,
you'll just fucking go nuts.
And,
uh,
I always lived in the valley and had
shitty parents with no money and lived in
crappy apartments.
So I was just going nuts.
I would go to other kid's houses and use
their garages and use their tools and I
never had a garage.
So when I got older,
I then went nuts with it,
but I realized I didn't have any money,
so I had to sort of shut that part of
my brain off sorta like being really,
really into like,
you know,
uh,
high,
high end strippers,
but working at an Rv.
So,
you know,
like he has certain point,
you go just go home and beat off,
like stop banging your
head against the wall here.
It ain't gonna happen.
So I'm working as a carpenter.
I don't have any money,
so I have to drive a pickup truck.
So I'm like,
ah,
just screw it.
And then a certain point I made
money and then once I made money,
I said,
it's time to overcompensate.
And that's where I'm at now.
And you have an addiction,
is it?
I think I'd say it is.
I mean,
in the sense it's,
I think about it more than
think about other things.
You were going to do the
American version of top gear,
right?
Yeah,
I did apply.
I did the pilot.
And what happened?
Uh,
what happened is,
uh,
about the worst sort of combination
that can happen when you're trying to,
uh,
be gainfully employed.
Um,
did the top gear pilot
with all the British guys.
I was sort of the lead
guy came out really,
really good,
really strong.
Everyone I could tell it was good
because all the hardcore blogger guys or
really deep into this world,
the top gear world,
they're international and they're just
a bunch of bunch of car tech nerd guys
who love to get on the computer and say,
Talk Shit about,
you know,
not,
not the,
they'd love to say not as
good as the one in the UK,
but they all showed up at the taping.
It did secret taping somewhere.
Some,
it was like 700 people showed up and
they all got back to the computers and
went,
oh,
it's every bit as good as the UK one.
Uh,
it was for NBC and it was right at the
time that a GM and Chrysler and a w two
of the big three I may
was Chrysler and GM.
Uh,
we're heading to Congress trying to get
money from Congress to stay afloat and
they're making a big deal about them
taking private jets to ask Congress for
money.
And the show,
Knight Rider Point,
0.2 0.0 was tanking completely,
and the writings on NBC,
so they're like,
no car,
no car talk and no car shows.
And they shelved it.
How fucking stupid.
Then I got another Sitcom,
a development deal with NBC.
And right at the time that happened,
it got picked up by the
history channel or discovery,
whatever it's on.
It got picked up for 13 episodes.
So they called me.
They're like,
Oh,
good news.
We got picked up.
And then I'm like,
no,
I'm actually doing another pilot for NBC.
That's a sitcom,
so I can't do it.
So they went ahead and did that.
And guess who Sitcom pilot
didn't get picked up?
So,
oh,
for two,
essentially.
So it's like you couldn't
fuck it up anymore than that.
See,
that's one of the beautiful things about
the podcast is that it's so difficult
to fucking develop a show.
It's so difficult.
I've tried developing sitcoms.
I'm a development deals event,
you know,
I've been from the ground floor,
I've been brought in during
pilots to try to make it better.
It's fucking just,
there's so many people involved in so
many opinions and producers and network
executives and it's so difficult.
One of the beautiful things about
the podcast is there's no one,
I mean for you,
you have a few people that you've hired
that figured out your audio stuff and
your video stuff,
but there's no one to tell you anything.
It's just you.
Yeah,
I know.
Beautiful.
Well thing like this.
It is.
It at least it is the
vision of the artists.
A handset,
as I've always said,
what piece of art,
whether it was a painting or symphony,
got better be because 14
people try to cluster fuck it.
You know?
And by the way,
whether talking about NBC or CBS,
five post-menopausal broads who never
made a human being laugh in their life,
get involved creatively.
I mean,
can you,
what goes on during the height?
I mean most of the executives in,
in the world of,
and,
and listen,
I'm not speaking as a bidder,
whoever they paid me my money,
I did my thing.
I have no,
nope,
no qualms with them.
And I'm not coming from an angle of,
Oh man,
I'd love to kiss their ass and get another
bite of the apple and the not coming
from an angle of,
um,
uh,
bitter jilted Sitcom pilot star
that didn't get on the air.
I'm just coming from
the angle of the truth.
And these people are not funny now at all.
Not at all.
Now the thing is is that's okay.
Most people aren't funny.
That's don't try to direct fund,
but,
but my mom doesn't tell me what set to do,
but you know,
before I go out on stage and so not
being funny and being heavily Merced in
comedy and funny and explaining
to people how to be funny,
what is funny is not going
to create a better product.
And my fantasy and,
and most of these,
a lot of them are women.
A lot of them are dudes who don't talk
and even have a little bit of a sour dour
look to themselves when they go back to
their high school reunion in the in like
Michigan or wherever they're from
and they say to their buddies,
so they haven't seen in 30 years what?
Where are you up to?
What will you live in in California?
What's going on?
What are you doing for a living?
And they go,
I'm the head of comedy programming on NBC,
or I'm the head of comedy
programming on a major network.
The people that went to high school
with Muscow kicked the fuck out of here.
You've never said a fucking
funny thing in your life.
Are you nuts?
You've never,
I never heard you fucking say thing
that made another human being smile.
What'd you do?
Stand up all through college.
I can you imagine how fucking confusing
it would be because to a lay person and
remember when you were a lay person,
you thought,
well,
if somebody is the head of comedy,
whatever,
this dude must be the
funniest cat in the land.
Right?
I must know funny,
at least at least.
And he's going to be student fat
guy named Marty and his officers,
Groucho Marx photos from the
[inaudible] going to love it.
Gotta love it.
He's going to be able to
do a bill Cosby bits and,
and uh,
you know,
Bob hope bits in everybody's bit just for
Beetham just back to you like a savant
and said instead of
looking at you and going,
I never heard of Mr Show.
Is that one guy or is that,
I've said that to you.
I uh,
I pitched,
I pitched a,
well,
first off,
sometimes you're talking to like 29 year
old chicks who fucking haven't heard of
all of,
all in the family.
Yeah.
With,
with a clipboard and a confused
look on their face and you're like,
right,
I'm selling something to,
for real.
Ah,
it is just,
again,
it's the death of all art,
which is a bunch of
opinions that that's it.
I mean,
even if even if someone's stood next to
Michelangelo and had a decent opinion,
it still would have fucked
it up to some degree.
Even a helpful opinion.
Well,
especially comedy because comedy
is all about one unique opinion.
It's all about one person's point of view.
When you start getting a bunch of other
people intersecting their points of view
into your point of view,
then it's not yours anymore.
Then it becomes some way,
like what makes someone funny?
Like talking about top gear,
like Jeremy Clarkson's my favorite,
I love that guy.
And uh,
his point of view is always
crass and slightly afraid.
It's uniquely his,
whether he has writers are not,
you know,
hey does he,
I'm sure I may not be a dick,
but I met him,
he came out when I did
the podcast and he was,
I'm sorry,
did the car never thinks of podcasts now
when I did top gear and he came was the
nicest guy in the world and I was just
improvising up a storm and he came here,
came right up to him and he said,
I could not do what you do.
I do not do that.
And I said,
oh,
thanks for the compliment.
And he said,
no,
I mean it,
I have my stuff figured out.
I don't know if he has writers.
Well,
he writes,
he
figures his stuff out and then
does it in such a matter of fact,
sort of way that it feels so organic.
It doesn't necessarily,
to me it feels like it's well written,
but it feels like it's his,
you know what I mean?
Well,
coming from your trained eye and ear,
but I'll vet to the average bloke.
It feels very off the cuff really,
man.
I Dunno,
it doesn't seem off the cuff.
It all in me.
We'll see.
Because when he's driving and he's having
this visceral experience and he starts
into sliding in a corner and he yells,
you know,
this thing smoother
than the Queen Mother's,
you know,
rear end feels like he's
having this experience,
you know?
Right.
That's why it feels like it to me.
And I'm,
I'm sure it's all canned,
but you know,
he's,
there's no teleprompter and
it feels like this again,
this experience,
it's transcending just the voice.
You can tell the doc,
I really fucking loves cars.
There's a,
when he reviewed the corvette Zr one,
and,
uh,
he's a sliding sideways down
this road and he's screaming,
well done fat man from Kentucky
and this is a masterpiece.
It's sideways blowing
smoke out of the tire,
stomp on that 648 horsepower engine.
You're hearing the roar.
You could tell that guys really loving it
in one of those that I think was a,
a Callaway or something and you know,
had the turbo on it and probably
at 900 horsepower when I met him,
uh,
down at,
like El Toro,
he just comes burning out.
I mean,
yeah,
not on camera or anything.
I was yelling at Steve Coogan,
who's English comedian who was criticized,
uh,
Jeremy Clarkson said
something about Mexico.
So that the reason why I'm
Mexico doesn't have good
people in the Olympics is because
all of their people who can run,
swim,
or jump have already
gotten over the fence,
you know?
And,
um,
people were shitting on him calling.
Apparently Steve Coogan was just joking.
Apparently he's like a joker and
their friends or something like that.
So,
sorry,
Mr Cogan.
Oh,
he wasn't really,
yeah,
it wasn't really shitting.
And he was like,
I guess it was his sense of humor.
I just missed the comedians
are making jokes is that,
you know,
in,
in terms of society,
in terms of fixing the ills of society
and looking for someone to point a finger
at and create some sort of social change
comedians telling jokes and has this,
why is it the top of everyone's list?
I mean a news caster,
you know,
politician clergymen there,
there's,
there's enough to the bankers,
chief of police.
When those guys make an off color remark,
uh,
then maybe you should
say something about it.
But when a comedian said something in him,
don't you already know
inherently by his title,
right.
That it's a job.
I was having this exact conversation last
night with Daniel tosh about comedians
going after comedians cause you know,
Coogan going after Jeremy Clarkson and he,
we were talking about David Cross
going after Larry the cable guy,
which was one of the
most confusing things.
I liked David Cross and I
like Larry the cable guy.
I think Larry,
the cable guy is funny.
He's,
is he the greatest comic in the world?
Well that's up to you
for some people he is,
he's a good joke writer.
He's a good,
he's,
he's got a good character.
I think it's good.
There's nothing wrong with it.
I absolutely not.
And I,
I would never go after one of those guys
cause it always just seems like sour
grapes.
It's like all right,
you're not selling out exactly ultra
domes and thus you're pissed off about it.
And this is what I got accused
of when we were attacking men,
you know?
But I'm just like,
look man,
there's,
there's a lot greater than him that is
way more successful and I'm not going
after them.
Like it's,
it's not a sour grapes issue.
It's a,
it's an artistic issue
when you go after someone,
when you go out,
you're someone who's doing something.
You don't,
you don't agree with you,
you don't like as material
fucking obviously someone does.
Are you saying that your,
your sense of humor is
the only one that's valid?
You know,
like you can't enjoy Larry the
cable guy and no one can enjoy it.
Will,
there's,
he's a racist and he says
racist things and no,
he says a lot of things that a guy that
was Larry the cable guy would fucking
say dry.
And it would be funny having a guy in
a flannel tee shirt with cutoff sleeves
talking about a ray blam angering.
I'm damn towel aids.
That's what he would say,
you know,
should fucking character.
Well listen,
you know,
Andrew dice clay did the same except
Andrew Cain kind of became that guy.
Andrew,
you know the dice clay Andrew was Angelo
Civic Silverstein and the dice man was
one of his many characters,
right?
He would go up and do John Travolta.
His fucking John Travolta is deadly.
He would go up and do all these different
characters and the dice man just
killed so much.
It eventually became him.
And then,
you know,
everywhere he goes,
he's wearing weightlifting gloves
and leather jackets and shit.
Well,
I a
guy,
I think he's had to re,
what happens is,
is that with these careers is um,
Gail again,
you know,
a year after Gilligan's
island goes off the air goes,
uh,
Bob Denver goes,
ah,
fuck this,
I'm not wearing that stupid white hat.
And the red crew neck sweater thing,
the white pants,
like I bull shit.
And then he does about 10
years of this is bullshit.
And then he does about five
years of soul searching.
And then at some point he opens
the closet and grabs that hat
going down,
open that fucking boat show in Long Beach
and walk out of here with nine grand.
And then it starts and then it starts
to wax the stouts trick about it.
So I think,
uh,
the dice man put down the pack of
cigarettes in the leather vest and said,
ah,
I'm going to do some other things.
And then a certain point realize
ain't paying the bills doing it.
Do you remember when he had a sitcom?
He went,
he went clean for,
right.
He had a sick on CBS and it was called
blessed this house or something like
that.
That wasn't it called.
That was like when kiss went on mass and
it was with the woman from raging bull.
Yeah.
What the fuck is Hellman Roche Rossby Aye.
I mean salad.
The fuck was her name because she was
super hot and then she got Chubby as fuck.
Yeah,
she's a and o d deann.
No,
not the Angelo.
Um,
fuck is her name.
Cathy Moriarty.
Moriarty.
Yeah.
Machine or a hot as fuck.
And then you know,
much like all of us,
she fell apart.
So the daisy Duke girl.
Oh and tattered box.
Sorry to comic book convention.
It was the saddest thing you will ever
see her sitting there with her little
short,
but they weren't as
short as they used to be.
Just sitting there.
No one talking to her.
No one even knowing that
she's sitting there,
I just walk up and I'm like,
this is daisy Duke right here.
She goes and I'm like,
Oh,
you're signing autographs.
He's you guys $25.
I'm like,
oh no,
that's right.
And I was like,
can I take a picture?
And she goes,
yeah,
that's $10.
I'm like,
no,
it's the no with my camera.
And she goes,
yeah,
it's $10.
But it was the saddest thing ever.
I'm like,
no thank you.
And I just walked away.
And this little daisy Duke just sit
in the corner by herself sitting at a
folding chair.
Can I tell you something?
That's Saturn,
uh,
moments ago when Joe was like,
you know,
what's the name of that author?
And they put the fatwa on the guy,
remember and,
uh,
wrote satanic verses.
Remember that?
What was the name of that guy?
And I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
that author member,
he had to,
he had to hide because they'd put it,
put a hit on him and Cat Stevens,
uh,
you know,
gave a two thumbs up and
what's the name of that author?
And I'm like,
uh,
yeah,
I,
I damn couldn't tell you,
but when you're like,
um,
I saw daisy Duke,
Catherine Bach,
fucking sad.
Well,
when we were kids,
she was hot.
I know.
Fuck sad that that's
where my knowledge base,
that old though.
How old is she?
She looks probably about 50.
So it's just the booze.
Is it?
Look just like sadness,
sadness,
booze or drugs.
It's a,
it's amazing how the booze really jacks.
Yeah,
there's a little,
weren't there as
much anymore?
She's done.
But then you look at like,
um,
Christie Brinkley's still hot as fuck.
Well somehow or another
she's keeping it together.
She's like 53.
I have this fun imaginary game.
No,
I like to play when it gets stone,
which is a sort of the acts,
it's like it's,
it's a cross.
Okay.
And let's say when you
were in junior high,
let's say you're,
let's say you're in the seventh
grade for the sake argument and uh,
Duke's a hazardous hitting its prime,
the good old boy and a blown up down
house with a crossbow and whatnot.
And you're,
you're just sitting there and you're
seeing an episode that has Catherine Bach
tight daisy dukes.
And she does that thing where she leans
over the open hood and the steam comes
out and everything.
And now there you are,
little Pecker Wood in New Jersey
in seventh grade and you're fine.
Now you're at the bottom of each acts.
You couldn't get further away.
There's,
it's not like you stole
a bus ticket to La.
You could fuck Catherine Bach.
No Way.
You're a million miles away.
So true.
Okay.
But now,
now you start heading up the
legs of the ax just to Google.
Now we move on 10 years.
Joseph,
standup comedian,
getting started,
having a little success,
making a little money,
grown into his body and it's just
become sexual sexually charged.
He's 23,
2123 years of age now.
A dukes of hazards been off the air,
you know,
uh,
15 years.
Yeah,
they've been off.
Well,
no,
I'm saying at this point,
yeah.
Okay.
Let's say it's been off 10 years,
10 years,
but she's still,
she's 36.
They're looking pretty tight,
you know,
whatever.
But Joe's not looking too bad either.
And Joe starting to do a little standup,
whatever.
At what point,
Joe,
at what point do you cross her?
Like at a certain point,
I mean,
when you're in the seventh grade,
you were sold your fucking soul and killed
your step mom to get one liquor that
pussy.
Right,
right.
But now,
but now,
but if I asked you right pulsive
if I asked you this second.
Yeah.
Well then obviously you guys crossed.
Yes.
What Year did you cross?
That's,
that's my game.
And then,
but,
and then there's something like,
Ooh,
you haven't crossed Christie Brinkley yet,
or maybe you're meeting maybe
about nine months away from,
from just hitting right in the middle.
If Chritton and Christie
Brinkley's still above me.
She's got me.
Yeah,
she's shy,
but maybe she's still hot
and she's 53 you know,
she's like 57 Oh,
Jesus.
That's my point.
She's going to be 60 maybe I crossed
her at 57 but she looks great.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe she does it with TV.
You can never really tell.
I'll have to ask Christine.
We'll,
we'll see what we can agree to.
An awesome,
yeah.
The,
the Catherine Bach thing,
it all depends on how much
Catherine Bach took care of herself.
Whether or not she was still in movies.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
There's,
there's some women that
even though they've,
they've kind of deteriorated there,
still have a level of respect.
News radio.
She's
been off TV for 14 years.
You know what I'm saying?
Once fear factor happened,
I had her mine,
she was mine when I was hosting.
If I want him to get Katherine,
I don't work out some
sort of bracket list,
you know what I mean?
We're just really,
you could find all the chicks you wanted
to fuck when you were in the eighth
grade and see when you cross them,
there is nothing stranger than watching
a woman go from being beautiful and
having ultimate power.
A really super hot chick,
super hot.
21 year old chick has almost,
it's almost voodoo.
You know like their body and
the way they move and like toy,
they smell and if they like you and if
they're smart too and if you're not sure
if you can get them,
God damn,
it's almost fucking vote.
Its ultimate power.
It's super celebrity power.
The reason why celebrities gets so
ridiculously fucked up trumps everything.
The reason why celebrities get so
ridiculously big headed and she goes,
everywhere you go,
people are kissing your ass.
Everywhere you go,
people are,
here's you know,
free bottle service.
Here's a limousine for free,
please eat at my restaurant.
You're amazing.
You've changed my life and you
start thinking about the shot.
That's an awesome thought,
Mr. Rowe.
But girls from the moment
they're little from the moment.
They literally are so cute.
You're so beautiful.
And then they're in high school
and then it becomes currency.
It becomes the thing that defines them
and then it goes away and it goes away
slowly.
It goes away.
Weird when they start looking
like that rough bar girl,
you know,
like still hot,
but in our thirties but you know,
he could see her at a cigarette and maybe
I'd get a couple of shots of Jack and
you and let's just go fuck in the woods.
You know,
just some crazy bitch.
It's just,
she's not the 21 year old
grows that cheerleader who you,
it was impossible to get.
Now she's just wild bitch.
He's just,
yeah,
you feel forced.
You're trying to pay our bills.
You know she's been divorced,
you know,
and then eventually they become monsters.
They become this weird thing,
especially if they get,
they go down the surgery route,
please ladies,
please just get old.
Don't go crazy.
Don't fuck with your lips and your
neck and all that nerdy shit does,
does not make you look better.
It makes you look different and that
different is not a good different,
it's a weird monster.
Different,
well,
you guys are going through historically
a bad phase because your mother didn't
have to worry about plastic surgery
because it didn't really exist and your
daughter won't really have to worry about
it because they'll have perfected it.
You even are,
you are in network engineering.
Yeah.
You're in the experimental
phase and it ain't working out.
It's Sorta like CGI that it's a bad
generation because our folks were watching
movies that every stunt
was an actual stunt,
just done by duty,
didn't give a shit.
And our kids enjoy CGI.
That works so effectively.
You can't tell.
We went through a whole phase where we
had to watch shitty movies with really
bad effects.
Yeah.
Because they were perfecting it on our
watch and we were sitting in the theater,
well now we're in the
theater of plastic and all
you women,
it's accent.
You're essentially,
it's the 50 year experimental phase
while they're working on it and you're
looking like,
shit,
you know,
I have to compliment you because
Brian Cowen said this about you and is
absolutely the truth.
You are the best at taking one scenario,
whatever it is,
and just going on this fucking rant.
Amazing.
Coming to these awesome conclusions.
You know,
it's,
you're,
you're dead on about it.
I love that.
Bryan Callen,
by the way,
I ran into that guy and,
uh,
we're shooting a movie and
just doing a little bit
part and a little bit movie.
And Brian came up to me and he said,
uh,
you know,
you may be the best at
doing this improv stuff.
And I said,
uh,
I don't know,
and there's probably other
guys to do it better than me.
And he said,
who?
And I said,
I don't know.
And he said,
well,
someone's gotta be the best.
And I said,
I guess they do.
And he said,
well then that's you.
And I was like,
all right,
exactly.
Story in those exact words,
I've walked away,
I've never fucking felt better in my life.
It's true,
man,
you go on these wild rants,
but they come to conclusions,
they're like,
they'd come to great conclusions.
Like I don't know,
uh,
how you generate material or if any of
this stuff you've already talked about on
stage,
but seriously go back and listen to
this podcast with a fucking notebook.
And there's like three good bits in there.
At least.
I never listened to anything
or go back and read anything.
That's how I,
that's how I wrote the book.
I swear to God just said,
you have to listen to all
this stuff and find the stuff,
the stuff out.
But it's always sad because I've tried
it a few times and a few times the guys
were gone and listened to a couple of
shows and then I go find anything good.
And they're like not so much.
And it's like,
oh,
you mean I didn't say
anything fucking good.
You got to get them better
guy should get a better dad,
a better guy that going a
little bit of crap comb.
Get a guy and make them get
high before he watches you.
That's very important.
We were talking about this,
you know there's a lot of people say,
Oh,
you're always talking about pod while
he was talking about pot because it's
fucking awesome.
Alright,
and it's awesome and it has
this terrible reputation,
this wrong,
incorrect reputation because of fucking
Nancy Reagan and just say no and Nixon
and all the nonsense and
propaganda that they force fed you.
It is a plant that is
here and it has benefits.
A great benefits for your mind.
I to pretend that it
doesn't to me is ridiculous.
We did a few things.
We started lumping drugs
in under one umbrella.
Absolutely true.
Just like you would no sooner do it with,
you were just talking about women.
Hey Joe,
I would like to shut you up with woman.
You'd be like,
what colors her hair?
How tall is she?
How old is he?
What's a color size?
Someone says you hate women because women,
some women,
one woman.
So it all just became drugs and some how
methamphetamine and marijuana just sort
of got lumped in under the same umbrella,
which is drugs and such a huge mistake.
And then the other
thing that drives me insane about our
legal system when they pull those guys
over who went on to rob the
north Hollywood bank over
there and Laurel Canyon,
that's crazy.
Motherfuckers who were like,
and by the way,
they were beaked out of their mind on
uppers and that's why the steroids,
the steroids and everything else.
But all right,
they pulled those dudes over in like
Eagle Rock and they popped the trunk of
their car and they found a ski masks,
police scanners,
um,
body armor maps,
uh,
automatic weapons that
were modified illegally,
I mean semiautomatic weapons and were
modified to go full automatic with armor
piercing rounds and extended
banana clips and stuff.
They found everything and the trunk
of their car that basically said,
oh,
these guys are on their way to rob a bank.
Um,
when they arrested them,
they could not get them for attempted
bank robbery because the law says,
Hey man,
we've got to catch you robbing a bank.
Just because you're driving around police
scanners and armor piercing bullets
and ski masks doesn't mean
you're going to rob a bank.
We know practically it means
you're going to rob a bank,
but the way our law system,
the system works is you have to rob a
bank and then we will prosecute you for
robbing a bank.
And we all agree,
all right,
that's how it works.
And these guys got locked up for
a little something something.
And when they got out,
they gave them back a lot of their
police scanners and a lot of their shit.
That was their property fine.
Then they robbed the bank and then
they had the north Hollywood shootout,
which was completely and utterly insane.
But the point is this,
we could not prosecute them for robbing
a bank before they robbed the bank.
And how come when you get busted for
more than a shoe box full of marijuana or
even a coffee can full of marijuana,
you get intent to distribute.
They don't have to catch you distributing.
Maybe I just like to stock up on weed.
That's insane.
That's an insane part.
A lot to me because every other thing
works is we need a body for murder and we
need a witness for attempted murder.
This is the only thing where they go,
you were going to do with this pot
even though they never caught you doing
anything with it.
And again,
maybe you like to shop like you
shop at smart and final or Costco.
We just want a 55 gallon drum
of garbanzo beans and you,
that's your fucking business.
That's how I used to do it before
the [inaudible] stores came around.
I used to buy in bulk because I
didn't want to deal with these guys.
You know,
there was a dude named Jake the snake,
then Eddie Bravo's friend that we used
to have to fucking deal with and used to
buy weed from him.
And he was this,
he was so stupid.
And Eddie Bravo.
So you know,
black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu choked
out one of the first guys to ever choke
out a great team competition.
And this fucking idiot was like,
man,
you could do that shit to me.
Eddie had strangled his kid three
times on it's fucking front law.
Do you kid do that again?
You got lucky.
You had to do it.
And again,
and yet,
and this kid was so stupid and
we were buying weed from him.
And so,
you know,
I would just buy a big pile of
us interact to deal with this.
God,
please shut the fuck up.
Here's the money.
Please shut the fuck up.
It's so sad that you can't,
as a homeowner and a
taxpayer just plant a pot,
plant your backyard.
You can row,
you can now,
but the problem is federally you can't,
you can't statewise you know,
as far as the state's concerned,
you know,
it depends on,
each county has a different law,
but you can have a certain amount of
clients and a certain amount of pot,
you can have up to like a half a pound
of pot and up to x amount of plants.
As long as you have a medical
recommendation or if you have a waiver,
you can get even more plants,
which I do have a waiver
because I need extra,
I could waiver.
And my dad gave me that fucking waiver.
My mom had a pot plant in her backyard
when I was like in the sixth grade.
Really?
Yeah.
And I told my buddy,
uh,
Hameed and the next day it was gone.
He stolen.
Wow.
I'm just doing the Hamid math on that one.
What a Douche bag Amit is.
Yeah.
I never told my mom.
Wow,
she's a big Joe Rogan podcast
or she's going to hear it.
Sorry,
mom.
Yeah.
And the uh,
yeah,
the weed thing is that I,
I've said this many times
and I think I said it,
my book,
here's,
here's the difference
between weed and other drugs.
I would rather have 1000 guys that smoked
weed live in my neighborhood rather
than one tweaker oh yeah.
Just one fucking meth head.
One method.
And you see them,
you like,
I think I,
we need to get rid of that guy.
Think about killing them.
Right.
You know,
like there's a disease person.
It's like I'm watching the show walking
dead that I just bought the DVD,
the set pretty fucking bad ass.
Good Zombie show.
But you know,
there's a,
there comes a point in the show where
people get bit and they're all sitting
around in front of figure how,
what are we going to do?
And some people want to kill
the guy and some people don't.
But you know,
a method is just like a Zombie.
It's like this guy's infected.
I mean this guy is fucked up.
He could do anything.
He can kill you.
He could do anything to
try to get this shit.
They have terrible decision
making capabilities.
They're almost like just
a high functioning Zombie.
I mean,
it really is.
Yeah.
And idea that,
I haven't checked recent statistics,
but about five years ago,
this country spent more on pot
eradication than it did on math.
And that's utterly insane.
It's just insane.
It's just a financial thing.
It's 100% of financial thing.
And there's a huge industry and
keeping marijuana illegal as far as law
enforcement,
as far as you know,
the,
the people in pharmaceutical companies,
they want marijuana to stay illegal.
There's a lot of bad fucking cops
out there when it comes to drugs.
And one of the things they do,
and this is a common thing
in the grower community,
they rob pot dealers,
cops do,
and they did it to a friend of mine.
A friend of mine was growing and his,
his neighbor turned him in
when he was growing legally.
So the cops came and you know,
they,
they ask them questions and they go
over all of his shit and he goes,
you're alright,
you're legal.
And then a couple of weeks
later he gets home invaded.
Okay.
Yeah.
By Cop.
Wow.
By fucking cops.
The guy says freeze pulls a gun on him
and it goes freeze and my friend goes,
freeze,
what the fuck are you saying?
What are you a fucking cop?
And the guy panics and shuts out in.
It became this crazy fucking situation
where he even is pretty short,
knows who the cops are but can't say
anything because he doesn't want the cops
coming after him.
He had a fucking move.
He hit a move cause he got
rob by cops.
What's up with the neighbors?
I,
that's my big question.
Up to the fucking neighbors.
I've had so many shit ball
douchebag neighbors called
the cops over nothing like
building departments involved with things.
Like I've never had a cool neighbor.
I had no idea that there
would be this many ass wipes.
Like,
I mean I've had,
I had a New Year's Eve party where the
cops showed up at nine 45 on a Saturday
night on New Year's Eve,
which meant the guy called
him at nine or you know,
it takes cops a good hour to
fucking roll on one of those calls.
Somebody called on new years eve at
like eight 45 to come to my house.
It wasn't raging or,
and it was just a bunch of people
sitting around having a beer.
Uh,
and the fucking cops showed up at nine 45.
And the cops,
the cops walked in and I said,
you want me to turn the stereo down?
And they said,
not if you don't want to.
And I said,
even the cops knew eight luck.
If it's 4:00 AM and you guys are just
fucking cranking a helter skelter,
uh,
is loud as you can,
well then there's going to be a problem.
But he,
the cop walked in,
looked around and just went,
oh,
this is bullshit.
And I released this one person who was
sitting home alone would wanted the
hundred and 50 people to all go home
because he wanted to fucking finish
watching his Hannity and Colmes or
wherever the fight is on at 10 o'clock.
And it's like,
what the fuck?
I've never called the cops and my life,
I,
I'll put earplugs in,
I'll put a shade all knock on the door or
and,
and go,
hey man,
this shit's really loud.
Is there any way we can
just lower it a little?
I mean,
if it's really crazy,
when I lived in apartments,
you know,
but I had good neighbors in the mountains,
the mountains when I
was living in Colorado.
It was kind of interesting because you
kind of have to help each other out up
there.
You're all alone with mountain
lions and bears and Shit,
you know.
And they'd give like good
advice about like what to do,
have a pair of tax you and shit like that.
But they were,
they were there different up there,
man.
But there were really far
apart from each other.
You know,
everybody was a drive,
you know,
everybody was a quarter mile
walking distance from each other.
Yeah.
That Helms fuck yet helps,
man.
That's the worst thing about La.
And I'll tell you what,
you being on your podcast the other day
completely reignited my escape from La,
a scenario.
And I been talking to Mrs Rogan about
it and we fucking started looking at
houses in boulder again.
We started talking to real estate guys
about the move I think is we're going to
probably look to get a summer place and
then eventually try to move into the
summer place and then know,
you know,
and you get the fuck Outta here.
But,
but the problem is that number,
the number of people when you've got so
many people and they're stacked on top
of each other and uh,
you know,
there's one guy next to her door
and it's fucking dog is barking.
I was over a friend's house the other
day and right next door to her house,
her dogs,
these dogs are barking like fucking crazy.
And then behind her there's some other
dogs and they hear these dogs barking.
So they come and triangulate the parking.
There's parking from here and parking
from there and everybody's jammed on top
of each other and you're fucking TV's
too loud to hear your songs on it.
And everybody's laughing by the pool.
There's too much input,
there's too much.
Nah,
listen,
I agree.
Even on a personal level,
I ever share a bachelor apartment with
a chick or just like a single with a
chick is fucking almost impossible.
Hard to get along.
It's just literal square footage.
When you're on top of each other,
you're fuck,
you have to be so fucking
compatible and so cool.
You know,
when I tried it,
I was 21 and the girl was 20 and we
were both poor and we're both working,
you know,
I was trying to be a comedian and she
was trying to manage restaurants and we
never lived with anybody before.
We'd live with their fucking parents and
all of a sudden we're living together.
It was ridiculous.
It was a terrible idea for me.
And Catherine Bach were shit
up in [inaudible] 79 but
the girl was great before
that and I was great before that,
you know,
I'm sure she probably thought,
yeah,
like,
you know,
he's so fun and it was
so much fun to hand.
I tell everybody,
like whenever they ask about like,
uh,
you know,
relationship stuff,
I just go square footage.
Like when I go,
what's your marital advice?
Square footage.
And to Tiva us the LDF spread it out.
Don't hate anyone you
have to live on top of.
Do you appreciate when you go on the road
when you read on the road and then you
come home?
Yeah,
that makes man,
you know when you're around,
you know everybody all the time.
He feels around you and burn anybody.
When you're around them all the time.
You know,
you just get sick of them.
It's boring and it's the same input is
coming in over and over and over again.
And you start analyzing that input.
That's why people started going,
why do you fucking do that
thing with your fingernails?
What do you give a shit what
I do with my fingernails?
Because they see you
doing this all the time.
If they just met you and I
saw you biting your nails,
like,
oh,
he's biting his nail
wouldn't be a big deal.
But you live with someone and you see
him biting their fucking nail every day.
You want to break their fingers off.
What are you doing?
You crazy ass hole.
I,
when I go on the road and I come back,
I'm so thankful.
Like Risa.
Yeah.
It's like,
it makes me so much more
enthusiastic about everybody.
Plus sleeping on a shitty mattress
with a just pentagram drawn in her.
It just make you miss your pill.
It's just a little bit of talking
to captain just over here.
If I left this motherfucker
throws loads on the walls.
He calls it Spiderman hotels because
that can cause you can't do it at home.
It's like Vic case and
say throw it everywhere.
That's roommates but well the only asked
the question is cause cause really on
the walls.
This is one of the reasons why when
I go to hotels every time I can I get
a sweet.
Yeah.
Cause I know guys like you
and not going to get sweets.
And so I'd have to look at
what Oh loads everywhere.
Literally throw it,
you know,
blow shoots it in his hand and
then throws it like Spiderman.
Oh cause it's turned the
corner on this activity.
Know.
But now he's starting to like it.
It's great that you're just
beating off into a wall.
Some poor lady from Guatemala has
got to clean your loads of photos.
This is a picture of a man in a canoe
fly fishing and it's got a load on it.
She's got a scrape it off at a nice
hotel that where they have like black
wallpaper.
I wouldn't do it on it against the wall.
It's like these crappy hotel walls that,
can you see anything?
That would be sweet.
Retribution as if it was,
let's say it was a hot hot August night
and you're staying in a bad motor lodge
and the air conditioning.
So on the Fritz and you're in like you're,
you're in the south,
you're in the deep south and you blow
your load and he'd go to do your Spiderman
fling with it and it hits the
ceiling fan back in your eye,
get pink eye and then you have to explain
to the doctor that's your own load
that gave you the pink eye.
I don't think that's enough.
I think he deserves more what more
of a well deserved to get pregnant.
I had payback the other day.
So yeah,
I don't even want to talk about,
it's fucking disgusting.
Let's just say that I came and then
somehow it ended all my lip snowball.
It's kind of snow.
The joke,
she thought it was funny.
What?
Nothing.
You came,
I can't just,
I was getting a blow
job came in her mouth.
Then like she later she
was kissing me on my lip.
She thought it was funny.
Oh,
that's rude.
I can't even watch the,
uh,
when the guy,
you know,
are going at the same time.
Like I,
I mean I can watch it,
don't get me wrong,
but what,
I mean,
this is the other dude's Jizz on you.
I,
I feel like not enough is made
of that in the porn world.
Like the boat just bust the load on
her tits and then they'll both be like
slapping their dick on it.
It's like,
Whoa,
buddy makes it lower loads here.
That's bad.
But how about when they're doing the
double vagina thing and they've got to
Dick's inside the pussy at the same time?
I'm like,
at that point in time,
you're not even fucking a woman anymore.
You using her vagina as a container
so that you can rub dicks.
Right.
What you're doing.
Yeah,
you might as well just to get a
tennis ball can and leave it up.
Get your buddy and stuff is cocking it.
Fucking pussy feels awesome,
bro.
I don't even feel your
balls against my balls.
It's just as pussy that
feel so awesome man.
You know,
I think it takes a lot
to be a male porn star.
I think that's the whole thing.
Like,
I'm sorry,
it takes a lot.
It takes math,
it takes abuse.
Takes a stepfather.
I was talking to one guy and I was like,
I don't want to say these names,
but I was talking to
this one guy and he goes,
I was asking,
have you ever met this other porn star?
And he goes,
yeah,
but you know something's
weird about him on the boy.
He goes,
he has his own sewing machine
and he always so lucid his
own clothes and I don't
know,
it's something weird and I'm like,
wait a second,
what's on here?
It's weird,
but that's what's weird is
that he has a sewing machine.
You asshole.
You like making clothes,
you know,
like,
I hear about Adam Kroll all the time.
I don't is a fucking carpenter.
You Know Adam Carolla does like his own
extensions on his house and Shit and you
do all kinds of crazy work,
right?
Nobody ever says the
fuck is wrong with him,
man.
What does he saw an shit?
No.
People go,
wow,
that's pretty bad.
Ass Guy makes his own cabinets.
That's pretty fucking cool.
But you hear a guy makes his own clothes
like fuck you fucking queer you making
your own clothes.
We got rhinestones all over to,
we got shiny shit on your clothes
so you're going to track some cock,
you know like what is that?
We all wear clothes.
What is wrong with making clothes?
I know.
The weird part was like having to be like,
yeah,
that is weird.
I kind of come close.
You have clothes from,
have a clothing line.
Then you're cool again,
11 year old Asians to make it for you.
Then it's hip again.
By the way,
the higher primary Joey Diaz
shows a shirts are sold out.
They sold out instantly,
literally within an hour.
All of them sold out except for small.
We don't have small fans,
so we need more Guido's.
More guys were in small shirts.
I don't really,
I got completely obsessed
world or new ones immediately.
I got completely obsessed with
this guy named Louis Wayne.
Have you guys heard of who this is?
An artist from the late 18 hundreds early
19 hundreds and the reason why I got
obsessed with him is that he's
just spit is cheers at the Camden.
He started getting
schizophrenia and so he,
he he,
his whole thing is,
he used to draw cats and he's your classic
cats for like the New York Post or I
don't know why,
some news famous Sainsbury,
but he starts to draw cats
in and he started getting
really sick and all his cat
pictures started turning into psychedelics
DMT art like you know that I've seen
that Alex Gray.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I've seen those.
Yeah.
It's so interesting.
So I just got obsessed with this guy.
It's very interesting to,
if you go online and look at
it and there's a book also,
it's interesting you talk about that.
The neurochemistry of the brain is
some fascinating shit and I've been
experimenting recently with Nootropics,
you know,
uh,
different things that
stimulate the mind like oh,
different supplements for the mind.
And we just started creating what
we've talked about this on the show
information on it.
You want me to tell another
Kareem Abdul Jabbar?
It doesn't matter.
Uh,
we'll,
I'll have all the information available,
but I started taking it,
but all the people that are taking wheat,
we've compounded all the best nootropics,
put it together and we're going to
release it because nobody has like a,
a brain formula go really
solid brain formula.
But all these people that are taking it,
they're saying their memories incredible.
The remembering all this weird shit from
childhood and apparently if you take it
right before you go to bed,
you have fucking insane dreams.
I started taking it two days ago.
You started hanging?
Yeah,
I should do it.
I do it when I wake up.
I should,
I guess I should do it when I got to go,
wait a minute.
It's not a really a selling
point because I feel like,
yeah,
cause like when I wake up at the best
night's sleep I get is when people got
like,
what'd you dream about it?
I'm like,
Eh,
I don't like this.
I
crazy dreams always.
My dreams are never,
my dreams are rarely good.
I have no dreams of grand chair there.
And they're not even horror.
They're not even horror
stories or just sort of boring.
Like I have these super
mundane boring dreams.
About half of them are
about high school football.
I can't find my,
my equipment and I never,
I never get in the game.
And the other ones are
just sort of Shitty,
you know,
jobs where it's like,
one of my dreams will be like,
oh you have this really shitty job
and it sucks and your board and then,
oh there's this hot chick who works at
the law firm that you're working at.
And then,
but you never fucked her.
And it's like nothing ever happens.
And then I actually wake up and I go,
Oh man,
I'm glad.
Like I'm glad to be awake.
Like whereas a lot of people,
well they wake up and they're not the
habit won the Heisman trophy and you know,
they're not fucking Lindsay
Lohan and they're disappointed.
I wake up and go,
I'm not working at a circle k and
driving my old Mazda pickup truck.
I'm actually relieved.
So I have these dreams
that don't set me up.
We are never had a dream
where I feel good like a,
I'm a,
I'm better in my dream
that I am in real life,
that I've done things.
You guys need to rent.
The action movie of dreams.
It's a nicotine patches,
you know,
for to cue you rent the action movie.
This is like renting an
action movie for dreams.
Take I take a nicotine patch,
put it on right before you go to bed.
You'll have fuckings Arnold
Schwarzenegger style dreams.
I mean just fucking insane mysteries
and action and helicopters.
Nicotine Patch,
the nicotine that ah,
your,
your nicotine receptors in your head.
Stay awake to suck in the nicotine.
So your brains a little bit more awake
than normal when you're dreaming.
That's why it says on the box,
don't take it,
but it's,
it's don't take it at
night because of that.
Because of that nightmares or dreams.
It's not nightmares.
It's fucking awesome shit.
Like fucking elevator dean is a confidence
inspiring sort of nicotine is a,
is a good drug.
Be A,
I would lobby the FDA to put two types of,
don't take this stickers,
right?
There's the one where it says do not
take this with alcohol cause your liver
will explode and then there's don't
take it with alcohol because you'll
supersize it.
Like essentially put it into sixth gear.
Now the ones where I can wash it down
with a couple of beers and feel that much
better about myself.
I'm all for that.
But I don't want my liver to explode.
Right.
Did you guys just have one sticker that
says no alcohol and I want to know which
one because all decide,
once I get that information I feel the
same way with the don't take at night.
Right?
Yeah.
It highly recommend it though.
Okay.
So what level do you take?
Like I always go with
level one and what it does.
I don't do level one level.
Once you're f your first week of
quitting smoking is the most strong.
Yeah.
I mean if you just want to have it good,
but I don't smoke so
what would I go with it?
Just level one really?
Yeah,
fucking that's eating like
a quarter of mushrooms,
really strong and dreams of drinks,
man.
Six hours of feeling like
a Xan Claude van Damme.
It's tobacco.
People don't understand tobacco in
itself or nicotine in itself is not a bad
drug and in fact it's shown to have some
benefits as far as like people's hearts
and actually it was like
good for your heart,
but the real problem comes with smoking
it and the real problem comes with the
599 these government comments that have
allowed these people to put 599 fucking
different additives inside cigarettes.
Most of them designed just
to make it more addictive.
If you look at that movie inside job,
that Russell Crowe movie,
which was based on a true story or what
does the inside man and when it's close,
yeah,
whatever it was.
That's what Jack those.
Yeah,
that was a great movie with
Jack [inaudible] Chemicals.
I'm flashing forward here
at Joe and flashing forward
about 30 years.
I'm seeing the kids
grown out of the house.
Wife's long.
God,
you're,
you're up now.
You're in the hills like year and the
year in the hills of Colorado at this
point.
Podcast still going strong,
strong this time.
Art Bell,
several million listeners,
mostly in China,
but all over the place
and now you're sitting,
you're sitting there with a full beard,
like a full gray beard
and some sort of bizarre,
um,
marijuana trips.
Sabaah story,
like all day slow drip thing,
constant buzz.
And you're going off about
precedent beaver and it just,
it just up there on your pulpit
with the crazy beers you're wearing.
You're wearing like three sets of glasses.
Like you have to buy focal painting
down the sunglasses up on your head,
your cats on your lap,
and you're just waxing
crazy poetic old man.
Talk,
lashing out against the government.
You're right next to me,
mother fucker sitting right.
And you're sitting right across
the aisle and you're like,
I'm so glad I got out of California.
Oh,
now building.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
You ever wonder what the fuck are you
going to be like when you be 60 or 70
years old?
Do you ever look ahead?
Did you try to live in the moment?
Uh,
I don't look ahead,
nor do I like live in the moment.
I just sorta am.
I'm just an atheist who is,
you know,
I have the things that I enjoy.
I have the people that I enjoy.
I do what I do just
because that's what I do.
Like I,
you know,
I don't really think
about things too much.
Uh,
I just,
I just think about things a lot though.
When you mean,
well,
what I mean,
this is,
I don't,
I don't plot the future per se.
I just essentially move through it and,
and I,
I tried to do it as efficiently
as possible and I try to
maximize whatever I can
maximize and what are my interests are
and financially and that sort of thing.
But in general,
uh,
I'm not a plotter.
I'm like not a down the road
or,
you know,
I have kids,
as far as college goes,
screw him.
They're on their own.
Like,
like they'll be fine.
They'll either want to go to
college or they won't go to college.
They'll either be curious
so they won't be curious.
Hopefully there'll be curious and I'll
figure out a way to pay for some of it,
but they can pay for some of it too.
Like I'm not one of those,
Oh my God,
what's going on next year guys?
And uh,
I never have been.
And you know,
I've been willing to walk away from,
you know,
many endeavors just because I figured,
well,
there's a new adventure around the corner.
I don't,
I don't look forward to it,
but I don't fear it either.
It's just there as a,
as it was for millions of other
people and it is for millions today.
Well,
you,
like I said,
you were the first guy to jump into
this whole podcast thing and you,
you know,
you went right at it right away.
What was your thinking like
after your radio show was done?
I know you were real frustrated by your
whole experience doing that radio show
and then after it was done,
did you just say,
let's see where this goes?
Because the podcast
scene was not anything.
What do,
I mean,
how long have you been
doing your podcast now?
Oh,
almost two and a half years.
Yeah.
Coming up on two and a half
years and a half years ago.
Man,
who the fuck out of podcast?
You know?
Well you were,
I did yours.
Shit,
I don't remember.
It was right after your,
your,
your show would close
and I remember thinking,
wow,
maybe I could do this.
Maybe this is something.
I was doing too many
different things at the time,
but I was like,
wow,
this was so much fun.
Like how cool would it be?
They just have a place where you can just
sit down and shoot the shit with your
friends and put that out.
Like is it going to be real well,
but you know,
what was your thinking after your show?
Tell us,
what was it like?
Like what was the radio show like
when it was canceled and you know,
when the,
the whole station we went to become
a Mexican station or something.
What happened?
No.
Became a like brought me 40 assumption.
You Lady Gaga Top 40 or 97.1
became a Mexican station.
Right.
Um,
the head have him talk.
I don't know.
I still,
I still think there,
I don't,
I don't know.
I know I still think they're
playing top 40 [inaudible] stuff.
But who you know,
who cares?
One or the other.
Both mind numbing when
one is mind numbing tip.
People speak Spanish.
Know Mind numbing to people that speak
English but their mind fucking numbing
music.
Both,
both sides.
The,
the point is,
um,
well what happened is they said to me in,
in this sort of weird mind,
fuck,
they said,
hey,
listen,
we're going to fold the station now.
Now for those who who,
you know,
don't know.
Uh,
I replaced Howard stern on the west coast.
a guy named rover did it
in the Midwest and then,
uh,
David Lee Roth did it in New
York when the change came about.
Uh,
the David Lee Roth experiment
ended super frankness,
super fast and the rover
thing and it fairly quickly.
And then I was around
and I was doing well.
We were getting,
I got bonuses in La toward the end and
I would always get bonuses and Vegas and
Seattle and Portland and stuff like that.
We were,
you know,
we had our ups and downs for sure,
but it,
it smoothed out and we're doing well.
And they,
and when I say,
well,
I don't mean conquering the world,
I just mean holding our own,
getting good solid ratings and getting,
getting occasional bonus
for being number one.
And they flipped the format.
They just figured out,
look,
why are we paying all these guys millions
of dollars to talk when we can just
play the four mentioned lady Gaga and
just make the same revenue and it's a
business decision.
Like I'm completely cool with it.
I understand like people are always like,
aren't you pissed off?
Fuck.
Now it's third.
It's their job.
They paid and I had a contract.
They paid me out the rest of the year for
not doing anything and it's completely
their prerogative.
I get pissed off at personal stuff.
I get pissed off when somebody
does something intentionally.
When the super selfish old
neighbor next door says,
I would rather watch jeopardy and peace.
Then have a 150 people celebrate
the ringing of the new year.
That's a personal bullshit thing.
When it's business,
it's just business.
I understand it.
So they were going to flip it,
but they said to me two months before
they were going to blow up the whole
station.
They said,
uh,
we're going to send you to New York.
You're going to the number one market
and we want you to take over in New York.
So,
but Shh,
don't tell anybody.
You cannot tell anyone
because nobody hears here,
knows the radio stations being blown up.
And the way radio works is they
don't give you two weeks notice.
They,
you finish your shift,
you walk off the air and the guy says,
go get that box with the weird
cardboard handles carved into it.
You're leaving.
And they do it for a reason.
They don't want you going
back on the air going,
fuck this station.
Fuck Jack Silver.
Fuck these cocksuckers these fucking guys,
you know,
they know it.
And most djs are nuts and that's
what half of them will do.
So they told me two months in advance,
we're flipping,
you're going to New
York and we're flipping,
don't say anything.
So it was this horrible two months for me,
or it'd be like,
it'd be like January.
And,
uh,
my producer would come up to me and go,
oh,
the,
the Wynn hotel wants us to come back
for March madness and do a special live
show at the casino.
And I'd be like,
Eh,
all right.
And she'd go,
so you want to set that up?
And I'd be like,
ah Nah,
just hold off on that.
Well,
they want an answer.
All right,
well then fuck.
I'd go ahead and do it.
Like what it was like,
I knew everything was coming to an end
and we were talking about shit to do over
the summer and stuff like that.
And so it was really weird
having these conversations.
It's like knowing you're going to get
divorced and your wife's making vacation
plans for the end of the summer and
you're going to serve her papers and two
weeks and that's tray and you're like,
she's gone.
You think ACO POCO would be awesome or
should we go to Honolulu and you're like,
whatever.
It doesn't matter to me.
And so at the very end they said to me,
uh,
by the way,
you're not going to New York and we
are still blowing up the station.
And I was like,
oh,
all right.
So that was the end of that.
You were going to go to New York?
I didn't know.
I had no idea at that point.
There are no jobs in radio.
There's no way to monetize a podcast.
I don't know what a podcast is.
I'm not,
I don't,
I'm not doing live shows
at that stage of my career,
I got nothing going on in a pretty big
monthly nut and not as big as the one you
toss at the wall.
For the folks who come in to the motel
six to enjoy shortly after you vacate
your room,
you sick fuck,
but still a pretty good size not right.
So I'm sitting there wondering what to
do and my buddy goes podcasts and I was
like,
well how the fuck is that
butter Donny at the warehouse?
This is podcast.
And I said,
how's it work?
He said,
you speak your opinion and
you and I are the same way.
We like,
we like to hear ourselves
talk and we have opinions.
And so I said,
yeah,
fuck it.
And I,
and I found out,
I said,
well how much you think
this is going to cost?
They said to you by two microphones and
a laptop and a Oh and then a little bit
for a bandwidth.
And I said,
well,
how much?
Oh,
it's like,
I dunno,
500 bucks a month or something.
And I was like,
oh,
I guess I could afford that.
Let's try it.
And then,
then it was like nine grand for
the first month of a bandwidth.
And I was like,
Holy Shit.
And so it got down to me spending like a
hundred grand out of my own pocket just
to do it pro bono with the notion that
one day it might turn into a business.
And that's really the
process we're in right now.
Wow.
So how did you go about,
I mean you have like this giant employee,
his staff,
this huge,
like a big room and all these employees
work in and people work in video
switches.
And how'd you go about finding all of
these people and putting everything
together?
Uh,
most of the people would hear
the podcast and just so like,
hey man,
I'm digging what you're doing and
I'm a whatever student and you know,
work for seven bucks an hour and could
I come down there and they just want to
be a part of something,
you know,
just in a sort of organic kind of way.
I'm sure
got in your offers.
If I didn't have a podcast in my house
that would be much more compelling put
the problem is it's in my house and on
some fucking weird off the internet.
That's how I met this guy.
Just saying you need to
others linger in there.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
So,
um,
do you had no idea when you first started
doing it that it would ever become
what it is now?
You were just trying to figure it out
and just do it and see what it became.
I never have any ideas about
anything before they are,
what they are,
you know,
I,
I just set and I just
embark upon the journey.
I know I don't really look
that far down the road.
I mean,
I understand I'm not
going to walk off a cliff.
I trust that I'm moving
in the right direction,
but I never have expectations.
And you know,
I have no shins.
Well you know,
let's,
it's sort of like this,
it's sort of a,
you know,
I probably got it a lot from,
from building cars.
Building is a process that
goes from shitty to good,
which is to say the first
part of building is,
you know,
permits and applications and you cut
and checks to the city for nothing and
inspectors and plan and Spec,
you know,
planned inspection and
all that kind of stuff.
And it's nothing.
It's just a bunch of money
and a bunch of papers.
You have nothing.
And then you start demoing and
digging stuff up and you know,
digging footings and grade beams and blah,
blah blah and putting in rebar and
waiting for concrete and all that.
But it's still,
it's nothing.
There's no shape to it.
It's just,
it's just a hole in the ground and you're
literally dumping money into this hole
in the ground.
But then at a certain point,
the cement drives,
you strip away the forms and you
start to frame and we start to frame.
You get to actually see the shape of the
structure start to unfold before your
eyes,
but it's still like it's wide open.
It doesn't keep the cold out
or the heat in or anything,
but you can start to
imagine about what it might,
what it be like to put down that hardwood
flooring and to see all the cool top
notch viking stoves and sub zero's
going into the kitchen and all that.
Well that's the part you look forward to.
But if you're closing your eyes and
picturing your new Viking stove arriving
when you're forming your slab,
you're going to fuck up your slab.
Just focus on the form and know that
you'll get to the Viking one day,
but for now you're just forming heavy.
That is heavy.
That's a heavy and correct.
I mean that's a,
you got it.
That's being in the moment.
You sort of have an idea that it's
eventually going to come together,
but right now you're just framing it.
If it doesn't,
it doesn't.
But let me just form the
best whack and form today.
Yeah.
I don't really plan things
out that much either.
I mean,
this plant did,
we didn't plan this.
Now we started this out on a laptop,
literally was sitting right in front
of one of these and we had fucking
snowflakes coming down the
Ustream broadcast and we
fucked around with music and
all kinds of different things.
And then,
uh,
eventually we figured out how to
do it the way we're doing it now.
But it's,
it's still evolving.
It's still,
it's,
it's a con,
but for us it's been the best tool ever
for getting people to come into the
clubs.
And that's one of the things that
you've done to sort of monetize it.
You start doing live
podcasts and then live,
stand up.
And I remember when we
did the Improv together,
the Irvine Improv,
it was one of the first times,
I think we're the first time you had
ever done standup in like fucking 10 plus
years and killed.
You went out there and killed and you did
it like you'd been doing it all along.
It was thought that was pretty fun.
It was pretty fun to watch.
Yeah.
It always sort of maybe had it in me,
but I never,
I never pursued it.
I remember talking to you when
we did Loveline fucking many,
many years ago,
and you were telling me,
ahh,
stand up the audience.
I didn't like the audience is,
I didn't like,
you know,
I didn't like it.
And I was like,
wow,
that doesn't make any sense to me because
you're funny and you like to rant on
things like you just condense
that we should package it,
put it on stands.
I mean that it is what it is.
Like
the rush of making 300 people plus,
you know,
laugh.
And when you're killing
in front of a large Carly,
like how could you not enjoy that?
It's weird because I get less out of
that then I get out of what we're doing
right now.
Really?
Yeah.
Because that's an environment and,
and you get the energy of the environment.
But right now there's somebody with
ear buds in each ear and they're either
walking their dog or they're walking on
a treadmill or they're walking their dog
on a treadmill.
Fun.
And what we're saying is penetrating deep,
you know,
and that's more of a party where you
just kind of getting caught up into it
versus a serious deep penetration.
And I'm really interested in just sort
of taken my ideas and inserting them into
you more than I am sort
of entertaining you,
so to speak.
You know what I mean?
That's interesting.
So why did you start doing standup then?
Just to monetize?
I just did it for,
I just did it for the money and I,
and I did it.
And you know,
it's funny cause people do
that thing where they go,
hey,
why'd you do this?
Or why did you do that?
And the answers for the money.
But it doesn't mean I don't dig it.
And it doesn't mean especially,
you know,
cause I've had this,
this problem in the past,
right?
I said,
look,
I'm going out to,
you know,
Kansas City,
Milwaukee and,
uh,
one more place turn theater.
Oh Wiltern theater,
uh,
in May and so and so forth
and Portland and wherever.
And if someone said,
hey,
you want to come out
and do a show for free,
the answer would be no.
So the US,
the answer is I'm doing it for the money.
I mean,
sad,
but it's true.
It's not sad.
Now here's the deal.
It doesn't mean I'm not going
to fucking show up and kick ass.
As a matter of fact,
if I was doing it for free,
I just pull up a stool and go,
Charlie Sheen on your ass.
I don't do that.
I realize that everyone is,
they're paid 40,
50,
60 bucks for a ticket and we're in a
theater and I'm going to fucking burn some
calories.
I sweat through a t shirt for you guys
telling jokes and trying to amuse you for
90 minutes.
So,
um,
would I rather be home watching my Tivo?
Hi.
Yes.
Uh,
am I doing it for the money?
Yes.
Am I also doing it because I
just have the ability to do it?
I mean,
it comes easily to me.
It's not,
I'm not trying to sound like a Douche bag,
but it's like a sport.
You know,
I,
it's not a,
it's not a grinder for me.
It's not a tool.
It's polar opposite of what you,
you do on the podcast and be,
I mean,
you can't say it comes easy to you.
What I mean you can,
but I mean the reason why it comes
easy to is because you're doing,
it's like,
it's like someone who,
uh,
does all this power lifting and
plyometrics and throw those medicine balls
around and then,
you know,
and then someone teaches
you how to choke somebody.
Right?
Well,
Jujitsu came pretty easy to me.
Well that's cause you're a
fucking crazy physical specimen.
You fight.
And like with you,
when you're doing is you're
constantly and constantly piecing
together ideas and constantly
pointing out things that don't,
that stand up.
You're right.
And,
and it is a muscle that gets exercise.
But either way,
when we go do a show,
I'm not pacing around in my hotel room,
you know,
nervous ducking,
salvos of cheers at Brian throws.
Like I,
I'm Aye.
It,
it's easy for me when I do it.
And so you get paid well,
it comes easily.
And why the fuck not,
I've actually been enjoying it in
this weird sort of a curious k case of
Benjamin Benjamin buttons where
I've been going backwards.
You know,
like I started off on TV
and I'm discovering my stand
up in my forties which is
insane because everyone else starts
off and stand up and get some
away from it.
You've only been doing
standup for about a year now,
right?
Yeah.
Look about it.
It's about a year.
But you've already put
together a full hour,
you know,
and you're 90 minutes,
90 minutes and you're out there crashing.
That's amazing.
Well you writing this
stuff down or are you just,
these are just rants and you'd categorize
kind of the rants that
or categorize and a,
and I sort of have cues that helped me
figure out what it is I want to say.
And then it doesn't come out
exactly the same every night either.
But yeah,
it's,
I and I sort of mix and match.
I guess it'd be like a a jam band that
had a bunch of songs and change the set
list up on a nightly basis and maybe
they'd never get that good on one song,
but yet they could free form if they had
to and they would never get boring for
them cause they're constantly mixing
the set up sort of sort of that.
I never do my,
I said the exact same
way every time either.
I,
I mixed things up all the time.
I know pretty much before I go on stage
what I'm going to get into right away,
but I always leave the door
open for something else.
I always leave the door open.
If I get on stage and for whatever
reason this thought pops in my head,
I'll run with that and then eventually
get to the planned opening and then once
I get the first bit out of the way,
it's most more important to me
is to get that one solid chunk.
Just get that out tight and smash it.
And then once that's out
and everyone's laughing,
then we're going to go
wherever the ball's moving,
the momentum's going.
Let's go wherever the fuck we want to go.
I'm the say way and it's like that first
20 minutes it just went to be solid.
You want to get everyone on your side
and just get that first like 2025 minutes
and then it's like,
all right,
we've established this.
Now we have some room for lateral move.
I,
I'm really big on that
with the opening acts too.
I always tell them,
when guys open up for me,
I say,
the best thing you can do out there
is don't fuck around the beginning.
Don't,
don't just don't try a new bid
out when you first get on stage.
This is a cold audience.
Okay?
This is,
you know,
a lot of guys that are on the road,
like I take guys on the road of me,
they're used to doing sets in Hollywood
and they're used to going up and doing
10 15 minutes.
That's when there's a,
you know,
a host and a bunch of
other people on the show.
Mike,
this is a different experience,
man.
These are people who don't know
who you are coming to see me,
so they're,
they're willing to let you be funny,
but you've got to go out
there and go tight right away.
You've got to gain their confidence.
So most important thing,
if people don't know who you are,
gain their confidence right away.
You got to do solid type
material right up front.
Get them laughing and go,
all right,
this guy's a fucking pro.
And then they relax and they settle in.
They have a smile on their
face and they're looking
forward to hearing and then
you're,
you're smooth then smooth
sailing and everything.
But if you start off chunky and fucked
up and then you got to Dell like this
fucking guy,
then you've got to constantly re
earn their respect through your,
your struggle struggle
through your entire set.
It's like going out on a first date by
shoving your copy through the mail slot.
Save it for the third day.
That's get the save it
for when she loves you.
She knows your confidence level up.
There's a video or a,
I watched it online but it's
apparently pulled from youtube.
But I saw it the other night.
It's a HBS talking funny.
It's a Louis C,
k Ricky Gervais',
Chris Rock and Jerry Seinfeld.
It's fucking great man.
And it's one of the,
and I'm going to,
I'm pursuing this now.
That's one of the reasons why I've always
thought that this podcast in and of
itself could be a television show.
I was trying to pitch a show
based around the podcast,
but the show that I was pitching,
it was like,
it was like really produced and there
was all these little segments that we
would do every week.
And then I thought about it and I'm like,
I don't like that.
I'm like,
I liked the idea of a podcast because I
liked the idea of people sitting around
and talking about
interesting shit and it's,
it's fun and amusing to watch.
And it was proof positive
to me watching that talking.
Funny thing because it was just for comics
sitting around talking about standup
and it was fucking great man.
Especially Louis C K man,
he,
him and Chris Rock.
But Louis C K especially,
he's my,
um,
my number one inspiration right now.
That guy is,
uh,
I love what he does.
It mean the standup wise,
material wise.
My favorite guy is Stan hope.
I think Stan hope is to me he's,
he's fucking fully out there.
You know,
he's,
he really is a wild fucking drunk
every night and he lives in Bisbee,
Arizona and Doug Stanhope
when you first said Stan Hope,
I thought there's a dude named Stan.
Oh,
um,
hopes Branson.
It's doing stand up now.
Sorry,
I'm preaching to the converted
Stan hope to the choir.
Uh,
yeah,
Doug.
Stan hope cause you know Stan hope has
a fucking house and the window sills and
the outside of the house
are painted the Lop side.
These fucking craziest houses like
bright yellow with green and shit.
And he said no,
he's,
he literally is that guy.
He's not,
it's not,
it's not an act.
He's now Fagan.
He does all his shows and rock clubs.
He sells all his,
all of his tickets on Brown paper,
bag.com or whatever the fuck it is.
Brown paper tickets.
So everything is like
all produced in house.
Everything he does is all him.
He doesn't go through any
other normal channels.
He has all of his fans.
They show up and see him all over the
world and he goes on these fucking drunk
and Jaeger bomb rants and
they're fucking awesome.
I mean his standup to me like Stan,
his material to me as a fan
is my favorite to watch,
I think is Joey Diaz is stilled.
I think the funniest guy and if I'm going
to watch a 10 minute set of anybody on
the planet,
I would watch Joey Diaz Cause
Joey Diaz when Joey Diaz crushes,
when he really fucking slams it home.
Nobody,
nobody's funnier than him,
but as far as like a long set,
Stan hope is demand from eight to me.
I enjoy his material,
but I really enjoyed,
yeah,
sorry,
I'm sorry.
But I really enjoy Louis
C K I enjoy his materials.
Wow.
I really think he's a brilliant comedian,
but I really enjoy his work ethic.
I really enjoy his philosophy on
stand up and how he breaks it down.
I find it as a comic.
I find it so inspiring because he
throws away his whole act every year.
He writes a whole act.
He writes a full hour,
hour and whatever the minutes
films it for whatever,
showtime or Hbo,
who the fuck wants to buy it and then
he throws it out and start from scratch.
And because of that,
because everybody knows that he does,
then he's got this
massively loyal following.
People can't wait to come and
see him because they know,
hey,
we saw Louis last year.
You think he's going to be
doing the same material?
Fuck no,
he's not going to be
doing the same material.
It's going to be all new.
You know?
And maybe if you yell out bag of Dicks,
he'll do,
you know his bag of Dicks joke.
But for the most part this guy has got
90 new fucking minutes every 12 months,
you know?
And to me,
man,
that's just,
I hear shit like that and I get fired up.
I,
I want to,
I want to sit in front of the keyboard,
I want to start writing.
You know,
it makes me like,
it gets me jazzed up.
I get tired.
Actually I never,
I don't know anyone stand up act.
I've never seen anyone stand up,
act like,
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
I to watch stand up.
I have no interest.
Oh you're so it's,
that's so funny.
Idiot.
I just watch,
just watch like a Hitler and color and
then I just watch a ultimate factories.
I,
I'm such a gearhead.
I had no interest in comedy.
Well why don't top gear,
why don't they fucking snatch you up?
Fire one of those.
I'm working on a show for everyone
who was not Adam Ferrara as as we're
speaking,
but it's weird.
I have such a gearhead brain that
the second I'm done doing any comedy,
my mind shifts to vintage
race cars and I don't,
I never think about comedy.
That's hilarious.
Wow.
I don't dislike comedy or anything.
I just have no idea what's going on.
I don't know any of the comedians.
I've never seen their act.
I crazy
about like parallel thinking
though because of that.
I'd be worried about like going on
this long rant and then you find out,
oh,
that's on patent Oswald second CD.
Oh,
and it happens.
I mean,
it's got to happen.
Like,
I mean,
I was just watching SNL a couple of weeks
ago and Zach Galifianakis got up there
and he said something that I said on
the stern show and on my radio show,
you know,
10 years ago.
And it was an almost
exact joke that I said,
I don't think he ripped
me off that motherfucker.
Brody Stevens,
you're gonna if you're gonna name him,
I body spray,
uh,
call the acts.
You're gonna,
you're gonna.
There's gonna be a joke about it
involves the black community and,
and I just happened to say
it on stern and you know,
when the ax came out,
but I don't think that Zach
Galifianakis Acus was listening.
You could have very easily been this
SNL did it that those writers did it.
There's a huge issue now.
That was definitely his act.
I could tell it was,
I could tell he was doing
his stand up really well.
Like,
you know that thing where you go,
look,
you want to host SNL.
I've never hosted SNL,
but you know,
host SNL and he say to a comedian and
instead of collecting a bunch of jokes
from guys who don't
really know your voice,
you just go,
fuck it.
I'll do my,
I'll do a real familiar five
minutes of my act at the top.
I know it,
I'm confident with it and then
we'll get into the rest of the show.
That's what it felt like.
You have any desire to host SNL?
No,
I don't.
I wish I did,
but uh,
I don't just say it seems like something
that doesn't have to do with cars or
building to me.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
You're that much into it.
Did I?
That's all I think about.
I don't have any desire to,
ost has an s and l to me is like
you got to eat 99 pounds of shit.
Define that one juicy
steak at the bottom of it.
Right.
You know,
Oh,
this a juicy 16 ounce
t bone at the bottom.
All the shit that I had to eat.
I think it's more of a jelly belly,
but his doctor,
juror ever talk to you about addiction
of cars because that is an addiction and
it probably,
he's probably spending a lot of money on,
yeah.
Diction and the interest that
you get enjoyment out of.
That's positive.
I think when people,
people throw around that
word addiction all the time,
go ahead.
Uh,
it's continuing in that activity in,
in the,
in the face of adversity.
And it's like,
essentially if your wife says,
I'm going to leave you,
if you keep up with fill in the blank,
uh,
you know,
if your boss says he's got to fire you,
if you keep up with the booze drinking
or the pill pop under the is Dawson or
whatever,
whatever you're doing,
uh,
and,
and you keep doing it and then you lose
your job and then you get divorced and
then you lose your home.
You know,
that's addiction.
Uh,
if you can be,
and there's such things as
functional addicts as well,
but the,
the real sort of definition is,
is,
is it ruining your quality of life?
Like,
are you for having trouble?
Do you like cars more than you,
like your job or your wife?
That's a possible idea as well.
I do think about them more,
but I also understand
that it makes me work,
right.
Because need to carb and I went to
the garage and I went to whatever.
So I have to fund the habits just
like a junkie has to steel stairs.
So whenever I was dating a girl in New
York is the first person that ever told
him that I had an addiction
and that was pool.
I was playing pool
eight to 10 hours a day.
Oh really?
Although me,
yeah,
I was playing in tournaments.
I've got a blouse.
I tore my ACL ligament and
I couldn't do taekwondo.
I couldn't kick box for a while.
How to get reconstructive
surgery the whole deal.
And uh,
a buddy of mine,
uh,
and I started playing pool and it
started out just knocking balls around to
retards had played in a bar.
No,
I didn't know how to play.
And then I met guys
that really could play.
And when you watch like real pool place,
you watch them and he's like,
oh,
it's about gambling,
they're gambling and there's money on
the line and then it's about tournament.
And then you know,
you get to see pros play and I just
became obsessed with these balls moving
around on this cloth and the,
the fact that you have to
figure out exactly how hard
to hit the ball to make it
collide with this other bond.
You've got to judge the angle and
it became a massive obsession.
And the girl I was dating said,
you have to choose that.
You have to choose between me or pool.
And I said rack them up.
I had the same thing with foosball but
it wasn't as bad.
But it was,
it was seven,
eight.
I love fucking food.
Do you have your own foosball table play?
Cause that's really all you're really
battling in life is your shell.
You know what I mean?
I love food.
It's about foosball alone.
What a concept.
That's the only addiction that I've
ever had were somewhat well and pool.
Again.
When I was in Hollywood,
when I first came to la,
I didn't have any friends,
so the first thing I started doing
is just entering pool tournaments.
I was like,
well,
now I know what I'm going
to do on Friday night.
You know,
if I don't have a set somewhere,
I'm going to go into a pool tournament.
We find a pool hall to play and then a
assessment and pulled me aside and said,
I think you're concentrating on
pool more than your own career.
And it was true.
I wasn't writing any jokes.
It was just fucking
practicing running out,
you know?
It was just going over patterns in my
head and watch an accu stats tapes of
classic Johnny Archer Versus Earl
Strickland matches from the early nineties
dissecting his runout and plus it was
affecting his comic because I caught him
back in the day and he'd be like,
all right,
show,
hey wait,
this dude's playing a Brunswick
with a pretty fast felt and it,
and he goes for the
bridge and everyone else,
I don't know.
It felt it felt,
felt,
revealed yourself.
Oh Man.
I gotta eat.
Yo,
what the hell?
There's bathroom right there man.
Go in there and take a left.
It is a four 48.
You have to bolt.
Yeah,
I do.
I got to go try to beat my
warehouse and like the next,
uh,
25 minutes.
Okay,
well you know what we're going to do,
we're going to pause it and
Brian and I will come out.
We'll close it out because we were going
to do another half an hour because we
usually do about two hours.
But uh,
thank you very much for
doing the podcast here.
And like I said,
if it wasn't for you and
during your doing your podcast,
we,
I probably never would have started
this thing in the first place.
You're one of my favorite
dudes to talk to you,
one of my favorite guys to,
to go on your show because you're,
you've always got a unique and interesting
perspective that I might not have
ever considered.
You know,
and there's not a lot of
guys like that out there,
man.
Brian counts said about
you really is true.
You,
you truly are the best at going on these
crazy rants that lead to conclusions.
Like I'll start rants off,
but then 10 minutes into
my rant I'd be like,
what the fuck are we
even talking about man,
fire up that vaporizer.
You know,
you'll,
you'll actually come to
conclusions on them and uh,
you're very unique cat man.
The whole thing that you're doing with
standup and thing that you're doing with
your podcast.
It's,
it's great stuff man.
And thanks.
Thank you very much for being on the show.
Thank you.
So that's it.
Adam Carolla.
Adam Carolla show.
Oh at the Wiltern is May 21st May 21st
this is a lie podcast show or status
stand up though.
Yeah,
Jimmy's going to join me out there.
Well good.
I think I'm home so I'm coming to,
I'm going to be there.
What Day is that?
That is a Saturday.
May 21st and it,
yeah,
La is a bitch as we'd always talked about.
So Elle is a bitch.
Hell,
come on out.
It's tough to sell tickets and
al lights not fall or Portland.
Find out cause there's so
much shit going on here.
What do you think it is?
I mean,
I'll,
I'll be,
uh,
I'll,
I'll give you the numbers.
Like,
you know,
the more theater,
you played the Moore Theater
in Seattle that holds,
you know,
1800,
1800 people.
Uh,
the Wiltern holds 1800 people or so.
And it's like the more sell out on a
Sunday night without really burning too
many calories.
You know,
I was like,
two weeks out,
we're 1400 tickets sold,
you know,
it's going to go clean.
As they say,
it's good.
We'll turn,
you know,
850 tickets sold.
Yeah,
we've got a month ago.
So probably be okay.
But it's,
it's,
it's tough sledding.
Like you got to fucking get on
it and hit it and work it and go,
come on people.
It's going to be a fun night.
Whereas the other shows are like,
Eh,
you know,
with weights on here,
right in sand.
Yeah.
Is there,
there's,
you know,
it just,
we're,
we're going to Milwaukee and we're
going to Kansas City and we're going to,
what the hell is the other boys?
Oh,
you got Milwaukee Friday,
got Kansas City Saturday and you have,
uh,
let's see,
oh,
sold out 12th.
Uh,
if they want it,
they can go to Adam Carolla.
Dot.
Khan,
Adam carolla.com.
But uh,
yeah,
but see,
for me it's my home town.
I'm from La,
so I,
it's sucks cause anyone,
it's like an Irish
fighter fighting and the,
you know,
in Dublin and everyone's like,
Eh,
fuck it.
We're staying home.
Like it sucks,
you know,
for,
for me,
this is my hometown.
And so it's like the Wiltern
is the theater that's like,
you know,
that is my holy shit.
I can't believe I'm playing this place
and now I want to fill it up because
obviously you play Portland
and it's half full house.
That's,
that's fine.
You don't feel great about it.
But that's Portland.
He didn't grow up in Portland.
I grew up in La.
Well La has so many
fucking options problem.
Let's not exercise any of
them on the 23rd that folks,
the 24 hour shelter in theater,
uh,
I'm,
I may be in Boston.
I'm doing this,
uh,
Kevin James MMA movie.
Kevin James is playing an MMA
fighter and I have to play myself.
Well,
tell everyone you're going to be there.
I will listen.
If I can make it,
I will be there.
That is Saturday the
21st thank you very much.
Pay everybody else.
Day Two and the Youtube folks.
I'm gonna walk out.
I'm out and we'll be right back.